let's remember where we all began we all
drew right-angled triangles right that
was the one thing I said make sure you
all do this make them whatever
right-angled triangles you like but we
have to all start with those okay so
Pythagoras theorem really begins here in
right-angled triangles and then we wrote
this sum we wrote this equation down in
the middle but that equation kind of
doesn't say very much in fact if you
look at this you know a week in the
future and you're like what was that
thing talking about you might forget
that we were actually doing
constructions and drawing things you
might just see all these letters and
think I don't remember what any of
that's referring to so that's why I put
some words here to explain what's going
on in fact someone in their feedback
forum wrote that one of the things they
love about I think it was drama is that
it allows you to express yourself in
different ways and on the board what you
can see is us especially the one same
idea in three different ways there's a
picture it's visual there's these are
symbols so symbolic is very short a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
and then we have all these words so this
is verbal right verbal visual and
symbolically fancy words but they're
just different ways of looking at the
same thing what does a squared plus B
squared mean it means we're adding up
two things it's a sum and what are we
adding up we're adding up two squares
and which squares are we adding do you
remember why we named a and B and B what
why we named them first yeah go ahead
there with the shorter side it's right
we start we just did them in increasing
size right so a and B were the shorter
sides and the squares that sit on top of
those shorter sides that's what we're
adding up when you do that they equal to
the big square the square on the longest
side the longest side has been an
awkward way of saying things by the way
so we introduce a new word hypotenuse
hyp o te and us a I've seen about 50
different misspellings of that word it
is notoriously difficult to spell so
that's why I've put it there nice and
big for you it's a bit easier to say
then the longest side which is three
words because like I said
they're lazy so a squared plus B squared
equals C squared if your diagram because
I know we all sort of struggled with
this a little bit because I asked you to
do something challenging in your book if
it's not quite matching up here's I'd
love you to do to finish okay we're
going to draw every time all of us this
time the same right angled triangle you
know how you all did different ones this
time we're going to do the same one and
I want you to do it in this particular
way measure this out so that the lengths
are these particular lengths make this
this sort of short squat side here make
it exactly three centimeters long this
one down the bottom make it four
centimeters long and then join them up
and then I want you to measure how long
it is once you've joined up those two
sides can you do that for me all right
now if you've drawn these two sides and
you've measured them out you should be
able to measure this last side though
what was it called again start with an H
the hypotenuse I know it's been a tongue
twister I promise you'll get used to it
okay how long is the hypotenuse how long
did you measure up five cents is it
exact
like is it five point one is it from
where nine so depending on how
accurately you measure these two will
give you how accurate this last site is
and I will show you why let's see how
Pythagoras's theorem works with these
three sides and how they relate because
in fact we don't even need to rely on a
ruler to measure this side we can just
pythagoras to do it if you've got
another color again you might hear me
saying this a lot extra colors are
really handy so if you do not have any
extra colors with you at the moment it's
like I have 15 black pens then I highly
encourage you to get a few other colors
even if it's just a highlighter or
something like that just helps you to
communicate a little more clearly I'm
gonna name these a and B and C okay so
in this case for this particular
triangle that we've all drawn now right
what is a squared a squared is
three squared which is equal to what
yeah that's equal to not very good so
three squared is equal to nine okay and
Pythagoras assumed the next thing I do
is I say plus B squared that's the next
sort of side in this case B is four so B
squared is 4 squared what's that equal
to yeah 16 regular 9 plus 16 now we know
what 9 plus 16 is right it's it's 25
which as you can see this is what we
looked at right at the start with things
that are not surd's right this is in
fact not just 25 we could write that as
5 squared or C squared right so you can
see this works here and in fact 3 4 & 5
the fact that they do that is really
cool these three numbers kind of hang
together as buddies right and because
they're connected by Pythagoras theorem
we actually say 3 4 & 5 we give them a
special name right whenever you you talk
about something over and over again you
give it a special name rather than just
to say hey you know that guy it's cool
here and he's like taller than everyone
we say merit because that's just so much
faster and more efficient right so we
give these guys a name rather saying you
know those numbers that do the thing
when they hair in the Triangle so we
call these guys a Pythagorean when when
you've got three children and they're
all born together at the same time we
call them triplets right they're like
kind of the same these are not the same
so we would kind of want to say triplets
but not quite we call this T every hand
up cuz you know the word or you're
asking you a question what's the way
very good triad is when you have three
things they're different as you can see
three four and five but they are
together in this particular relationship
three four and five are a Pythagorean
triad
full-stop
it's kerning okay and at this point he
works really hard well done you've got
this huge big idea in your hand and if
it's kind of like feeling a bit funny in
your brain in the moment that's okay
because for many of you this is the
first time you've encountered others of
you you're like no no I'm quite
comfortable I met I met this before no
big deal right
well to each of you I'd say number one
it was not comfortable yet relax we're
going to spend lots of time of the next
few years using this it will get
comfortable for those of you who are
already comfortable you're like no
totally know this stuff right I would
challenge you to see where else this can
go for example these are squares right
what do you think happens let's take
these guys no I'm just gonna leave them
there
what do you think happens if instead of
squares I put another shape like say I
don't know a semicircle
do you think that works don't don't try
cutting that into pieces that will be a
nightmare okay but do you think it might
be true that you could add up those two
semicircles and get that semicircle
Pythagoras theorem is a really deep cave
to explore we're gonna look at lots of
it over the next well waken of it and
also in your 9 10 and 11 questionnaire
yes radius is from the middle to the
edge and the diameter is from edge to
edge it's the longest distance across
okay